our continuing series what's working
looks at the innovations that are paying
off in America from education to
infrastructure and more research finds
that when students change schools
they're more likely to be less engaged
that could lower their grades and
increase the risk they will drop out of
high school students generally lose
about three months of reading and math
with each transfer mark Strassmann shows
us a promising new program for
low-income students and their families
at school in Atlanta it's cut the
student turnover rate nearly in half
mark good morning good morning
this is Thomasville Heights elementary
school historically a failing school in
Atlanta but there's been a turn around
here turnover is down attendance and
test scores are both up and it all
started when parents and their kids
lawyered up when Nicole Evans Jones
became principal here two years ago she
inherited a crisis Thomasville Heights
Elementary has at times been the worst
performing Elementary School in all of
Georgia and one of its poorest I have
students you know that have been in four
or five schools by second grade or so so
the class that starts on day one can
look very different than the class that
finishes the year absolutely absolutely
but like 40% of the kids in that class
might not be there at the end of the
year they knew they had to address that
problem and we thought we had a solution
Michael Lucas helps lead the Atlanta
volunteer lawyers Foundation a group
that gets attorneys to fight for free on
behalf of low-income tenants he traced
the Thomasville heights turnover problem
right across the street to the forest
Cove apartments 95 percent of the school
students live here it's section 8
subsidized housing families kept moving
in and out of here because they had no
choice
accommodation of wrongful evictions or
deplorable conditions that never seem to
get fixed the solution embed a tenant
rights lawyer inside the school's front
office a free walk-in resource for
parents really I get to be a lawyer in a
school helping parents and Families stay
in the school
zone so you get the benefit of the
school lawyer
Ayana jones light z says right away new
clients kept walking in the door so
these folks come in what kind of issues
are they having it's more a question of
what kind of issues aren't they having
mycelium fell on this weekend from a
leak that I've been telling my landlord
about for months my oven doesn't work
hasn't worked for weeks these folks are
coming to you with issues that are
violations of the law yes and they need
a lawyer yes and they can't afford one
yes Lolita Evans and her four kids live
at Forest Cove sick from the mold that
grew inside their apartment her
complaints went nowhere until she showed
up with her new lawyer what kind of a
difference did it make
Oh different I had a whole SWAT team
come to my door it came right here and
we can fix everything in one day one day
one day and you've been waiting for how
long about a year her lawyer was Jones
Lite see what kind of an adjustment was
it with a landlord to realize the tenant
had a lawyer I think it's still an
adjustment and these tenants don't just
have me they have lawyers from the top
law firms in Atlanta but they know you
mean business yes one of my tenants says
you know Ayanna don't play that's her
phrase for it last year the program's
first year here
the lawyer stopped 20 evictions they
took on over 80 cases involving
conflicts with a complex management I've
had tenants cry in court because they
knew they had a story and they knew they
had a right but they didn't think they
would be able to articulate it and win
dr. Jones says student turnover here
dropped from 40 percent to 25 percent
it's huge
yes I mean we still have a long way to
go obviously but it's a great start in
first year there's some far-reaching
really human impacts of this affordable
housing crisis and I hope that other
communities will take a closer look it
at those impacts jayanna Lolita Evans
can tell you about the impact we were
there as her kids
jayanna a fourth grader and Robert a
second grader received awards as
students of the month
the first year of the program
standardized test scores went up 50% no
one's calling it a miracle turnaround
but it's a solid start for CBS this
morning
mark Strassmann Atlanta yay mark
Strassmann so many heroes in that story
dr. Evans who took the job as principal
the school when it wasn't doing so great
Michael Lewis the attorney who organized
all that Iona Jones lights light to you
they said Iona don't play but I love
Lolita Evans who sort of lays it all out
and real talk about what goes on what
team showed up you got a yawn on her
side right but it does show you how
people can work together and figure
stuff out yeah and you know that we all
know what it's like to have that
incredible frustration when you're
fighting to get something you know you
have a right you know you're in the
right but but the system is against you
and have somebody deliver you through
that system on the other side and have
the benefit be that you are okay and
your kid gets to go to school I think I
think we all need anion or light see in
our lives thing we will be watching
thomasville element that's right
Congrats to all involved there